زينَةْ زينَةْ زينَةْ
زينَةْ كَاليَاسْمِينَةْ
زينَةْ تُسَاعِدُ مَامَا
ولَهَا فِى البِيْتِ مُعِينَةْ
زينَةْ تَلْعَبُ تَهْزِرْ
لَكِنْ أَبَدًا لاَ تَكْسِرْ
أَوْ لِلأَلْعَاَبْ تُبَعْثِرْ
مَعَهَا قِطٌ وسَفِينَةْ
تَرْمِى الكُرَةَ فَيَجْرِى القِطْ
يَقْفِزُ خَلْفَ الكُرَةِ يَنُطْ
تَضْحَكُ زينَةْ لَوْ يَسْقُطْ
بِالأَفْرَاحِ تُهَادِينَا
زينَةْ زينَةْ زينَةْ
زينَةْ كَاليَاسْمِينَةْ
زينَةْ تُسَاعِدُ مَامَا
ولَهَا فِى البِيْتِ مُعِينَةْ
فَهِيَ لَطِيفَةْ وحَنُونَةْ
تَرْسُمُ كَلْبًا بِالمَرْعَى
مَعَهُ نَعْجَاتٌ تَرْعَى
بِمُرُوجٍ خَضْرَا تَسْعَى
زينَة تَهْوَى التَّلْويِنَ
أَيْضًا تَقْرَأُ تَتَسَلَّى
تُمْضِى الوَقْتَ بِهَا أَحْلَى
فَالكُتُبُ صَدِيقٌ أَغْلَى
زينَةْ زينَةْ زينَةْ
زينَةْ كَاليَاسْمِينَةْ
زينَةْ تُسَاعِدُ مَامَا
ولَهَا فِى البِيْتِ مُعِينَةْ